today the Night wall show a New York
City Courthouse adorns its building with
a satanic Monument to abortion the
statue is creepy and depraved and also
hideous in fact our whole society is
plagued Now by hideous and creepy
artwork it's all part of a larger agenda
I'll explain today also project Veritas
caught a Pfizer executive on camera and
what he reveals is truly explosive stick
around to hear about that plus Eric
swalwell is traumatized after being
kicked off of the intelligence committee
for sleeping with a Chinese spy and
Google has massive layoffs leading to
some unintentionally funny Tick Tock
videos we'll take a look at those today
all of that and more today on Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
tragedies of my life is that I wasn't
doing a show last week when Boston's MLK
statue the news cycle came and went and
passed me by the thing that motivates me
to get up every day and Host this show
is the very hope that one day I'll be
able to deliver a monologue on something
as hilarious as a statue that's meant to
honor Martin Luther King Jr but instead
looks like a disembodied pile of Limbs
that arranges itself into a different
sex act depending on the angle you view
it from it's supposed to be a memorial
to King but the sculptor accidentally
made a memorial to Pornhub well I assume
it was an accident whether he meant for
the thing to be sexualized to be sort of
a sexualized three-dimensional Rorschach
test is anybody's guess but we do know
that what he created whatever the
intention was is a giant 10 million
dollar hunk of garbage
there's a lot to be said about the
subject not just to Simply point and
laugh at it
I mean mainly the point and laugh but
also to discuss the continued and
rapidly increasing uglification if I can
coin a term of our society this is a
process that is uh deliberate and
systematic beautiful art is taken down
and replaced by hideous vomitus nonsense
why is this happening what is the end
game
these are the important questions but I
missed my chance or so I thought to talk
about them that is until New York City
came to the rescue only a week after the
MLK sex sculpture uh revolted and amused
us all NYC has made their own
contribution to the conversation they
are attempting valiantly I might say to
recover their Crown as the ugly statue
capital of the country and with this
latest eyesore they may have succeeded
here's the article from a time out which
is a New York City News site says
statues of nine men from history and
religion perch atop the courthouse near
Madison Square Park
now for the first time the
representation of a woman has joined
their Noble rooftop plinths
Hava to breathe air life an exhibition
by artist Shazia sikander focusing on
things of justice has brought stunning
golden sculptures to Madison Square Park
and the nearby courthouse at 27 Madison
Avenue inside Madison Square Park sits
witness a Monumental female figure
measuring 18 feet tall and wearing a
hoop skirt inspired by the courtroom's
stained glass ceiling Dome the figure's
Twisted arms and legs suggest tree roots
referencing what the artist has
described as the self-rootedness of the
female form it can carry its roots
wherever it goes you can even use your
smartphone to bring the figure to life
through AR technology adorning the
nearby courthouse now an eight foot tall
female figure resembles the park
sculpture but a Lotus symbolizing wisdom
replaces the hoop skirt her horns
indicate sovereignty and autonomy a
delicate color nods to the late Supreme
Court Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg who
often wore detailed colors with her
traditional black robe the statue the
only woman uh represented sits next to
figures including uh Confucius Justinian
Moses zoraster at last this this work
puts a female figure on a level plane
with the traditional patriarchal
depictions of justice and Power
well not quite a level plane because
those other sculptures are legitimate
works of art this one is a satanic
monstrosity it's a woman with tentacles
for arms and horns on her head
resembling like a doodle that a very
disturbed ten-year-old might draw it's
the kind of thing that the child in the
horror film sketches at his notebook
right before his parents realize he's
possessed and on top of all that it
looks cheap as though it was sculpted
out of plastic it looks like it was made
of the same material they use for those
little green toy soldiers that you buy
in a bag at the dollar store this is
modern art in a nutshell cheap
ugly stupid and vaguely or not so
vaguely in this case demonic New York
City by the way is no stranger to ugly
statues just a couple of years ago they
confused us all with a monument sculpted
by a quote conceptual artist and placed
outside the Rockefeller Center that
looks like a giant cartoon head like
something that a not very talented
caricature artist might sketch really it
looks like a parody of African art
though the artist is black so he escaped
the racism charge I guess but he
certainly cannot escape the uh the
charge of being a talentless hack which
is what he is
now to add insult to injury
while New York litters its streets and
buildings with these unsightly lumps
it's also actively removing it's good
art
just a few days ago the city finally
removed the statue of Theodore Roosevelt
that has adorned the outside of its
Museum of Natural History for nearly a
century
the stated reason for removing this
statue is that the depiction of a black
man and a Native American man walking
alongside Roosevelt makes the whole
scene somehow inexplicably racist
no one ever explains why by the way just
the fact that you've got a white man and
then there's a black man there also
that's racist
but the real reason was taken down is
that the work of art commits two
unforgivable sins in the Modern Age one
it memorializes a a heroic white man
which of course you can't do and two
it's beautiful
that's a beautiful work of art
and beautiful art is no longer loud
of course you don't need to live in New
York or Boston to have your eyes
assaulted by these memorials to ugliness
every American city is plagued by these
sorts of Modern Art mutations popping up
everywhere like like tumors
a while ago
I mentioned this art display sitting
outside the Tennessee welcome center
right off of uh of interstate 81. so
when I'm you know driving if you coming
down from Virginia into Tennessee and
you stop off because you got to use the
restroom you'll be forced to look at
this now in times past they may have
welcomed you with a glorious
sculpture representing the state's
unique culture and history
instead they give you this weird orgy of
malformed Ambiguously humanoid shapes
and again you find this stuff everywhere
we were visiting Asheville Asheville
North Carolina not to be confused with
Nashville Tennessee not long ago and we
found ourselves gawking at this towering
pile of shapeless scrap metal which the
artist calls Passage
but should have just been called tetanus
and we could go on with examples in fact
a Twitter funnel this might be the worst
one
a Twitter follower sent me this photo
that I had to look this up because I
didn't quite believe that it was real
this is a photo of a recently installed
statue in Carmel and Indiana and the
statue is titled Rising Sun but instead
it looks like a hairy potato or perhaps
like something more anatomical in nature
perched on a misshaped platform of some
kind it has the aesthetic quality of
like a Nickelodeon cartoon from the 90s
except a lot more explicit
so what's going on I mean why are they
making this ugly nonsense why are our
cities pockmarked with these hideously
sculpted abscesses why are we all forced
to live in towns with the artistic
equivalent of skin cancer
I I think there are a few reasons
and the first is pretty simple great
artists have skill and they have
training and they have uh proper
education
our artists have none of those so
they're not capable of making anything
that rises to the level of classical art
I mean they they couldn't produce a
sculpture that could pass for something
sculpted 200 years ago even if they
wanted to
one thing is like notice the lack of
detail in all of these statues this is
the thing with all modern go to Modern
Art Museum it's the same deal there's no
detail in anything
the demon statue in the New York
courthouse is mostly just smooth and
featureless which gives it that kind of
cheap flavor and the artist didn't even
attempt to make arms or hands because
those are the most difficult to get
right and so instead they uh look when I
was when I was an art class in like
seventh grade I I used to do the same
thing I could I didn't know how to draw
arms and hands because they're difficult
and so I would do something like oh you
know I'm using my imagination this is a
person with uh you know uh tentacles for
arms instead easier to draw
the sculptor in Boston did make arms and
hands but that's all he made because it
requires Great skill to sculpt heads and
faces
so he simply left them headless
meanwhile the other statues didn't
attempt to resemble anything at all so
that there's no standard they can be
judged against
you know if you try to
make something that looks like something
then everyone can look at your art and
say well they can they can judge it
against what you're trying to capture if
they you know it's the thing if you make
art and you're trying to capture
something or actually say something
then then that gives people a frame of
reference that they can judge your art
against
and so all this in part is a cover for
the fact that these artists have no
talent but then even if they could make
something beautiful they probably
wouldn't
Modern Art is ugly because modern
artists can only produce ugliness and
also because they only want to produce
ugliness
we are witnessing as I noted at the top
the systematic uglification of society
they make ugly things on purpose because
to them to make an ugly thing is to
commit a revolutionary Act
they despise tradition they despise all
that came before us and their ugly art
is an attack on tradition all of this
garbage is the diametric opposite of the
sort of art that our ancestors produced
and celebrated and passed down to us
and that's reason enough for our
cultural Elites those in charge of
facilitating our cultural decline to
prefer the garbage
but most of all they make they make ugly
things because they hate Beauty
the artists of antiquity uh Made
Beautiful Things objectively beautiful
things that all human beings can
recognize as beautiful
and they did this in order to lift the
viewer up to bring them up and into the
experience of beauty whereas the modern
artists clouded by his own ego obsessed
with his own Hang-Ups and preoccupations
and anxieties creates things with the
purpose of dragging the viewer down
syncing them into a state of anxiety and
confusion a man named Jeremy Wayne Tate
on Twitter made this point very well he
wrote quote Renaissance artists aim to
uplift the viewer and draw them into
Beauty they were primarily interested in
their subjects modern artists aim to
shock and confuse their primarily
interested in themselves
and that is the truth no doubt
and Truth ultimately is the enemy here
as always
modern artists hate Beauty
because they hate truth
the left in general hates Beauty because
it hates truth
and as the English poet John Keats said
truth is beauty beauty is truth and
that's all you need to know on this
Earth they know it and they hate it and
so they give us this ugliness instead
now let's get to our headlines
our friends at genucel skin care have
exciting news to celebrate in 2023
they're introducing their new microbiome
moisturizer which uses the power of
probiotics to Target skin redness pesky
wrinkles Fine Lines patchy blotches and
other signs of premature aging these are
the same probiotics that are in your
yogurt as it turns out these super
ingredients can have the same nourishing
benefits on your skin as they do for
your tummy so if you've ever been eating
yogurt you thought yourself I want this
on my skin this is for you probiotic
extracts Target bad bacteria and uh and
it restores balance to your Skin's
protective barrier now every genucel
most popular package includes their new
probiotic moisturizer free with your
order my talent manager Tessa uses
genucel under eye treatment to help get
rid of the bags under her eyes and she
swears by it every day when we talk
about it right now you can get genucel's
most popular package for 70 off visit
genucel.com Walsh and get your probiotic
moisturizer today use code wall should
check out for an extra 10 off your
entire purchase that's genyourself.com
Welsh genucel.com Welsh
we begin with this news major news I'll
read the post-millennial report because
I don't know how well the audio will
translate if you can't see the subtitles
but you should go and watch the full
video after the show this is the report
though from uh post Malone says project
Veritas released a new video Wednesday
in which a Pfizer executive claimed the
company is attempting to mutate covid
via directed evolution in order to
preempt the development of future
vaccines
as a result hashtag directedevolution
trended worldwide Jordan Tristan Walker
Pfizer's director of research and
development strategic operations and an
mRNA scientific planner claimed that
direct evolution is not the same as gain
of function research which according to
the outlet is defined as a mutation that
confers new or enhanced activity on a
protein many of the virus in question
can become more powerful depending on
the mutation or scientific enhancement
Walker told an undercover project
Veritas journalist quote one of the
things that we Pfizer are exploring is
like why don't we just mutate covet
ourselves so we could create
preemptively new vaccines right so we
have to do that if we're going to do
that though there's a risk of like as
you could imagine no one wants to be
having a Pharma company mutating effing
viruses
he added
from what I've heard is they the Pfizer
scientists are optimizing the coveted
mutation process but they're going slow
because everyone is very cautious
obviously they don't want to accelerate
it too much I think they're also just
trying to do it as an exploratory thing
because you obviously don't want to
advertise that you're figuring out
future mutations
and then Walker pleaded don't tell
anyone promise you won't tell anyone the
way the experiment will work is that
we'd put the virus in monkeys and we
successfully cause them to successfully
successively cause them to keep
infecting each other and we collect
cereal samples from them
you have to be very controlled to make
sure this virus that you mutate doesn't
create something that just goes
everywhere which I suspect is the way
that the virus started in Wuhan to be
honest it makes no sense that this virus
popped out of nowhere it's BS okay like
I said you could watch this whole but I
think it's about 10 minutes
you see this whole conversation
um
where Pfizer executive is saying that
they intend to do the same thing they
did in Wuhan but we gotta be really
careful
it's like the the the
uh
the safety of the human race is at stake
and we're just going to trust that you
know Pfizer is careful
like they can do things that if it goes
wrong Millions will die
but it's all right because we could just
trust them to be careful
because we know that these people
historically have been very careful
right
now
uh I mean this obviously should be
breaking news in every media Outlet we
have a high ranking official advisor
admitting that they're working on
mutating the virus admitting that it's
the same kind of thing they did Wuhan
pleading that uh that nobody finds out
about it it's like how many how much
more explicit can you be yes we're doing
this dangerous dangerous thing please
don't tell anyone we're doing it
what else do you need to hear
big Pharma
must be stopped and I'm not interested
in voting for any Republican who isn't
serious about holding these psychos
accountable they've been operating with
impunity for way too long
way before covet way before code
okay before covet came along before the
game before the vaccines came along
how about turning half the country into
drug addicts
inventing diseases to treat and profit
off of
conducting dangerous experiments that
imperil the human race
injecting whatever they want into our
bodies lying about it the whole time
it's got to stop it we need Leaders with
the wherewithal to stop it
now I've already told you we talked
yesterday about about the the penalties
that I would prefer to see for drug
traffickers
so you know what I would like to do with
drug traffickers well let's start here I
mean let's start with the ones who wear
suits and have offices on the top floor
of fancy skyrises I mean after we try
them for their crimes and convict them
in a court of law
because that has to be the first step
we're way past the point of uh
Congressional hearings and
investigations we need both of those
things
but they don't mean anything if they
don't lead to trials and
criminal charges convictions punishments
and there are other actual policy
changes too that could be made if we
really wanted to rein in big Pharma
and some of this might seem slightly
indirect
but but really it's not and we need to
be doing it raining in big Pharma right
means uh either it means it's simply a
talking point something that you say but
if it's more than a talk about it means
it means cutting off the funds it means
taking money away from these people
that's how you do it
or that is at least a major part of any
effective plan to rein them in
another big part is
again criminal charges trials
punishments you got to take the money
away and I'll tell you one way to do
that we've talked about this plenty of
times on this show
ban the pharmaceutical companies from
advertising their products directly to
Consumers
um whether it's a pill that they're
pushing or a vaccine or anything
they should not be allowed to advertise
it directly to Consumers and that's that
is already the policy in almost every
country in the world
almost every country in the world most
countries they don't let the
pharmaceutical companies advertise
directly to Consumers that was the
policy in this country until I think it
was the mid 90s when the FDA changed it
the fact that this policy was changed
and has not been changed back
the fact that we we uh still allow them
to advertise to Consumers only shows you
that our politicians are in their
pockets because there's no good argument
for allowing this
I just read an article a couple days ago
and um I'll pull it up maybe tomorrow
we'll talk about this in more detail
because it's very important but
basically
you know according to this uh this
article
the drugs there's kind of an inverse
correlation here because the drugs with
the biggest ad budgets have the lowest
therapeutic value
and why is that
because drugs that work
and are safe
are actually safe and actually effective
they don't need to be advertised doctors
will prescribe them because they work
there's no reason to advertise it
okay if the drug works and it's
effective in all that then you don't
need to go to your doctor and ask about
it can I have this drug
no especially you go to the doctor with
your symptoms and and then your your
your illness is diagnosed and treated
but drugs that don't work need
advertising because they need you as the
patient to go to your doctor and ask for
them
and then they need to incentivize the
medical industry to distribute these
drugs whether they work or not
and the other thing that they do with
these uh with these advertisements
the drug adds
they're not just selling drugs that are
ineffective and potentially dangerous I
mean they're doing that
but they're also selling the disease
they sell the disease
right that's why all the ads are the
same they say do you have this XYZ
symptom well talk to your doctor about
this drug
they're not even asking you oh well if
you already have this disease here's a
drug for you it's like
let's convince you that you have this
disease
a disease that you might not actually
have diseases that might not even exist
because big Pharma they also invent
diseases that don't exist so that they
can treat them and profit off of them
and then once they've uh toyed with your
hypochondriac mind and convince you you
have this thing you go to the doctor and
you plead for the for the the pills that
uh that you want and then most of the
time you get it
um it there is no good reason to allow
this there is just no good reason to the
only reason to allow the drug companies
to advertise directly to Consumers is is
if you're very concerned about making
sure that the big Pharma Executives make
a lot of money that's the only benefit
the only benefit is that they make tons
of money doing this if you don't let
them do it they make a lot less money
there is no benefit to the to the
population there's no benefit to me or
you
it's only harm
I bring all that up because uh again
this is one way you reign in big Pharma
but also if you're wondering why nothing
is being done by the powers that be
um to hold big Pharma accountable
when it comes to covid and the vaccine
and the lies that we're told if you're
wondering why well all you need to look
at
is is is is this I mean
direct consumer Banning direct consumer
ads that should be a bipartisan this
should be one of those very rare
bipartisan issues because it should
appeal to both sides
the right pretends to be skeptical of
the pharmaceutical industry the left
pretends to be skeptical of Corporations
and corporate greed in general well here
you go here's an issue that both sides
should agree on
and they don't at least not in
Washington
because obviously they're in the pockets
of these of this industry
on both sides
all right
I'm sure you recall a few weeks ago when
there was great Panic across the land
because Republicans couldn't agree on
who to appoint as the new speaker of the
house and this was a source of
tremendous heartache and fear and misery
in the population and I mean
specifically the population of corporate
media offices in BC nobody else really
gave the slightest damn about any of
this nor should they have cared about it
but for those um particularly on the
right who are concerned that you know
not handing the speakership over to
Kevin McCarthy automatically concerned
that if we didn't just give it to him
that it would somehow have disaster
disastrous effects
I think those people should should check
out what Kevin McCarthy now the speaker
of the house has been doing over the
last several days
one of his first acts as Speaker of the
House was to to kick Eric swalwell and
Adam Schiff off of the house
intelligence committees which is a very
good thing
but the fact that he's doing these good
things is not evidence that we shouldn't
have resisted his speakership but rather
it's evidence that it's a very good
thing we did because it's clear that
McCarthy's uh resistance from the base
has resonated with him
okay we we do have some power and
control here but we have to use it
and even if it didn't provoke an
authentic conversion experience for
Kevin McCarthy it at least is forcing
him to act like something other than an
establishment shield for right now and
that's just as good as far as I'm
concerned I don't like frankly I don't
care if these people mean it or not I I
don't care I don't care what they
actually think in their hearts I don't
care about any of that doesn't make any
difference to me who cares about that
all I care about is what they do
the policies they implement
even if they do it begrudgingly if they
do it and they wish they didn't have to
do it but they're only doing it because
uh they're being held accountable by the
base and they hate us and they're
muttering about us the whole time fine I
don't care
just do it
is they're doing it to appease us good
that only shows the power that we have
so McCarthy kicked them off the
intelligence committee and then he had
this really fantastic exchange with the
DC journalists Who challenged him on it
and again what you're about to hear from
him you would not have heard had we not
challenged if the base had not
challenged him you wouldn't hear this we
and we never we haven't heard anything
like this from Kevin McCarthy until now
that's not a coincidence but we'll watch
a little bit of this Exchange
he's got elected by
his district so
okay let me be very clear and respectful
to you you asked me a question when I
answer it it's the answer to your
question you don't get to determine
whether I answer your question or not
okay and all respect thank you no no
let's answer her question
you just raised the question I'm going
to be very clear with you the Intel
committee is different you know why
because what happens in the Intel
committee you don't know what happens in
the Intel committee although the secrets
are going on in the world
other members of Congress don't know
what did Adam Schiff do as the chairman
of the Intel committee what Adam Schiff
did use his power as a chairman and lie
to the American public even the
Inspector General said it when Devin
Nunez put out a memo he said it was
false when we had a laptop he used it
before an election to be politics and
say that it was false instead it was the
Russians when he knew different when he
knew the intel if you've talked to
um John Radcliffe dni he came out ahead
of time and says there's no Intel to
prove that and he used his position as
chairman knowing he has information the
rest of America does not and lied to the
American public when a whistleblower
came forward he said he did not know the
individual even though his staff had met
with him and set it up so no he does not
have a right to sit on that but I will
not be like Democrats and played
politics with Thief where they removed
Republicans from committees and all
things
okay good yeah and then he goes on talk
about Eric's walwell I mean Eric
swalwell was involved in a romantic
affair with the Chinese spy so yeah
should he be on the intelligence
committee I mean he's involved in a
romantic affair with Chinese spot he
also has chronic flatulence so those are
two good reasons why I mean it's not
fair to the other people on the
committee to have him in there uh for
really both of those both of those
reasons
and uh that's the point that Kevin
McCarthy made well he didn't bring up
the flatulence thing I wish he had let's
see oh that's the only criticism I have
of this moment Kevin McCarthy a moment
that
once again I I do not believe we would
have if we hadn't
challenged him the way we did now
swalwell for for his part is very upset
about not getting his committee
assignment
is another one of those things right
that DC shows how
how terminally out of touch they are
with any normal American that they think
we care about like they can come to us
they think they can come to us with a
with a sob story about not getting a
committee assignment and they think that
we'll care about that they think there's
anyone in the country who's sitting
around going
I really feel bad for Eric swalwell not
getting his committee assignment
so he's addressing the media about it
and uh holding back tears he's very
upset
so this is purely about political
Vengeance the cost is not only removing
us from the committee on the
intelligence committee the cost is not
only breaking shattering the most
precious glassware in the cabinet a
committee that's always been bipartisan
the costs
are the death threats that Miss Omar
myself
and Mr Schiff keep getting because Mr
McCarthy continues to aim and project
these smears against us even though we
have said publicly
these smears are bringing death threats
he continues to do it which makes us
believe that there's an intent behind it
but we will not be quiet we're not going
away
I think he'll regret giving all three of
us more time on our hands
oh you made a threat there himself
that's a threat isn't it
yeah actually I am worried about Eric
swallow having more time on his hands
how many other
foreign spies can he sleep with in a
given year with all that extra time so I
am a little bit concerned about that
by the way nobody is making death
threats to Eric swalwell I don't think
anyone's ever made a death threat to
Eric swalwell no one would take him
seriously enough
to make to actually make a death threat
he's not a serious enough figure in
politics to Warrant that to begin with
but also
he wants us to believe that people are
making death threats because he because
of him not being appointed to the house
intelligence committee
no one is even aware of that or cares
and the kinds of people who would send
random angry death threats to
politicians these are not the kinds of
people who are
paying attention to what the committee
assignments are
so that's all all very good stuff all
right
Damar Hamlin after his cardiac emergency
on the football field a few weeks ago
we're we're told
he spent several days in the hospital
but he's now out
um though still in need of lots of
physical assistance including oxygen so
we're told
now Hamlin showed up to the bills
playoff game on Saturday or Sunday
whenever it was and they lost but the
big story was Hamlin's Presence at least
according to the media this is a big
story and he was up in a boxy he was on
the field he was up in a box he was
watching
and the announcers referred to him
frequently throughout the game uh
cameras kept showing him and and the TV
production made a really big deal about
him being there
the weird thing is that Hamlin
though he was on camera a lot he never
we never saw saw his face they never
showed his face he wouldn't show his
face and there are a few times where
they showed him up in the Box
seat but it was like you you it was at
such an angle that you couldn't really
see anything all you could see his
silhouette
got his face covered and all that
so um
so he showed up but they didn't want to
show him
and he didn't want to be seen
it it's a kind of bizarre and then any
kind of bizarre thing will lead to
theories on the internet
the internet theorists some of them
speculated about or wondered whether
Hamlin wasn't actually at the game but
rather was represented by some kind of
body double and then from there you know
from that theory then it branches off
and then it could get you know even more
implausible but
so maybe he's alive but they sent the
body double to the game so they could
get the the storyline of him being there
maybe he's dead you know and and this is
a body double that they put so all kinds
of theories like that as you can imagine
the media does not like any of this one
bit uh very upset about the theories
as this just one example this NBC Sports
uh article makes very clear headline
crazy disturbing Demar Hamlin conspiracy
theory emerges
it says in many respects the modern
world has lost its damn mind conspiracy
theories abound over everything uh and
it was unavoidable we suppose that some
nutty conspiracy theory would emerge
regarding Bill's safety to Mark Hamlin
our original plan was to ignore it to
give it no attention no Credence no
oxygen sometimes however it's important
for the rational to expose the
irrational so that some of the
irrational aren't tempted to swallow the
crazy ass cheese
what
who wrote this I wish I had
to swallow the what kind of writing is
this so they're not tempted to swallow
the crazy ass
first of all is that what do we do the
crazy ass cheese or the crazy ass cheese
which one are we talking about both are
disgusting but one is particularly more
disgusting anyway
uh how does how does the phrase crazy
ass cheese make it into
an article that is then published by NBC
News
how does that make it through the
editing process
what is your editor doing if they allow
if they're not going to flag you down
and say Hey you know the part about
crazy ass cheese I don't know if we
maybe would at least take out the ass
um
anyway as it relates to Hamlin there's
actually a theory complete completely
unsupported by a shred of evidence that
Hamlin died from the covet vaccine and
that he has been replaced by a body
double think about that one the person
who attended Sunday's game between the
Bengals and bills isn't Demar Hamlin
it's someone else disguised as Demar
Hamlin and presumably his family and his
teammates are in on it
and then it goes on and on and on and uh
it uh
you know scolding the people that have
spread this computer it's conspiracy
conspiracy theory around now a few
things about this first thing is that as
always actually the media
while they complain about these
conspiracy theories and they pretend to
be very offended upset by it they
actually like them and they want more
they want to encourage them that's the
only reason to report on this I didn't
know that this Theory existed until I
read some of the news articles
condemning it like so many other people
I only found out about the theory
because of the left-wing media
scolding those who were propagating the
theory but really they themselves are
the ones propagating it
because they like it they want that
now
I don't think Demar Hamlin is dead and
replaced by a body double okay I don't
think that for a lot of reasons I mean
for one thing just the sheer number of
people who have to be involved in a
conspiracy of that sort we're talking
about family and friends and doctors and
teammates the NFL the media like all of
them would have to conspire to remain
silent for what forever you'd have to
keep it going forever and pretend
pretend this guy's still alive and um
doing that so they can cover up what
that he I guess the idea is he that he
died from the vaccine well they already
gave their version of why he was in the
hospital so they if he died they would
have just blamed that they would have
said he died from the football injury
and uh if you think that there's some
sort of cover-up going on then that
would be the cover-up it's a lot simpler
and you don't need to enlist hundreds of
people across multiple Industries to
cooperate in this conspiracy to pretend
someone is alive for the next several
decades when he's actually not
um anytime you're theorizing a massive
elaborate scheme involving thousands of
people who almost stay perfectly in line
and silent and this scheme is like
hatched in order to achieve some
extremely negligible benefit or whatever
anytime there's a theory like that it it
Demands a lot of evidence to believe and
otherwise you should be extremely
skeptical doesn't mean that those kind
of theories are always wrong it just
means that I don't need to see some real
good evidence for that
um especially in this case when there's
a much more plausible explanation which
is that Demar uh my theory would be that
the Mars Hamlin's face got kind of
messed up from a stroke related to the
incident and he doesn't want people to
see like that's my that would be my
theory that's the most plausible sort of
explanation
um
which brings me to if there's a if
there's a scandal here you know the real
Scandal if there is one is that the NFL
insisted on making Hamlin they wanted
the story
okay that's the thing that's what the
NFL cares about they care about the
ratings obviously so the media cares
about they care about the ratings they
care about the story you care about that
more than anything else
and so
uh the moment this happened to
Damar Hamlin
the parasites in the media and NFL
Corporate Offices they were like
you know they were
they they saw the money signs and being
able to capitalize on this storyline now
they wanted a storyline and so that's
why they wanted to trot them out at this
game
you know insisting on making Hamlin into
some kind of hero some sort of like
martyr and uh and and and you know and
they really wanted that storyline of it
and in reality Demar Hamlin
suffered something very terrible
I feel very sorry for him
and that's it like that's that's there's
not much else to be said about it
but they wanted to make it a lot more
than that because they wanted the
ratings and they wanted the story lines
so they brought them out when he clearly
was not ready to be out there and they
exploited the whole situation throughout
the entire broadcast by going back to
him again and again and again and uh the
fact that he didn't want to show his
face just makes the whole thing all the
more bizarre and weird and and just uh
you know gratuitous I think
but you know also
as I've said before I don't the people
that indulge in elaborate conspiracy
theories oftentimes I don't believe
those theories the reasons I've said
but I don't blame people anymore for it
I just don't
because
there's been a total collapse of trust
people simply don't trust any of the
supposed authorities
that are supposed to be in charge of
you know disseminating information and
telling us what's going on
the public doesn't trust any of those
people anymore for good reason
and because they don't trust anyone then
everyone is left to kind of make their
own assumptions about everything
and some people tend to make more kind
of cinematic assumptions than others but
I think the blame ultimately goes with
uh
the people who have lost our trust
and have created this situation
all right
let's get to the comment section
foreign
[Music]
coffee company is on a mission to build
a support network for veterans First
Responders and law enforcement by
serving you the best coffee you've ever
had and thanks to your support that
dream has become a reality this year
alone Black Rifle coffee donated over
120 000 bags of coffee to Veterans and
First Responders while expanding their
own team of active duty service members
veterans and Veteran family members if
you want to continue supporting this
incredible company go to
blackrifflecoffee.com use promo code
wall should check out for 10 off your
purchase and your first coffee Club
order the coffee is truly one of a kind
but it's your support that gets gear
funding and supplies into the hands of
those on our front lines go to Black
riflecoffee.com use promo code walls for
10 off you can also find Black Rifle
coffee in grocery convenience stores
near you Black Rifle coffee America's
coffee
lftr says Steep and highly socialized
penalties work it's called a deterrent
as Society has backed off and reduced
penalties for Crime our cities have
become graffiti tagged crime-ridden
hellscapes this is not a coincidence
it's a direct result of choosing not to
punish criminal Behavior right of course
it is that's obviously what's going on
anyone who claims that punishments are
not a deterrent for Behavior this is
someone who is denying one of the most
basic realities of human psychology
including their own psychology okay
everybody is motivated by incentives and
disincentives
that which isn't to say that people are
directly uh perfectly controlled by such
incentives
now you can incentivize a certain
behavior and there will be some people
who still do not engage in that behavior
you can disincentivize certain behaviors
and there are people who still will
engage in that behavior uh so that that
will happen
but still people are highly influenced
by incentives and disincentives that's
everybody is so to deny it outright as
people do to claim that
you know
no matter how much we
clamp down on criminal behavior and how
much no matter how much we punish it no
matter how severe the punishments are
it'll have essentially no effect
on the frequency of that criminal
behavior that claim is
not credible at all
let's see Jay Anderson says from a
historical perspective drowning women as
witches was normal just because it was
normal in history is no justification
for the same actions today obviously I
hope
yeah which is why
my argument for corporal punishment and
uh and the increased use of capital
punishment my argument is not simply
based on the fact that people have
always done it
that's not my only reason
though it is true that um when it comes
to we hear cruel and unusual punishments
well these punishments are certainly not
unusual they are probably the most usual
punishments in the world historically
that's not the be-all and end-all of the
argument but that is a reality and it's
worth pointing out
because yes
the fact that something has always been
done a certain way is not in and of
itself a sufficient reason necessarily
to keep on doing
but it does mean that if you are
suggesting that we do things in a
radically different way
then you need to have a good reason for
that
it does shift to a large extent the
burden of proof over to you
okay if Human Society has always done
something a certain way and we've got
the the testimony of our ancestors going
back through the ages saying this is the
way to do it this way works
it could be that that we need to change
courses and not do it this way anymore
sure
but if you're coming along and saying
that if you're saying no let's cut no
work let's let's cut it off right here
and go in this radically different
direction because all those people are
wrong okay I'm I'm open to hearing your
argument I really am but you got to make
the argument
you have now assumed a burden of proof
that in so many cases
the people who are demanding that we
sever ourselves from our ancestors never
meet they never meet that burden of
proof
instead they try to go the other way the
other way it's almost like
for a lot of people
the fact that our ancestors did it is
reason enough to not do it
and that's supposed to be self-evident
which it isn't
and these days we do have
many people have anyway a radically
different concept of what constitutes
Justice
and what uh and and and you know how we
should deal with and punish crime we
have a radically different notion of it
today
a notion that would have been totally
foreign to most people who've lived on
earth
that in and of itself doesn't make it
wrong but you got to be able to defend
it
and defending essentially by just saying
well corporal punishment for thieves is
that that just makes me squeamish I
don't it doesn't makes me feel weird
that seems to basically be most people's
argument and I don't find it
particularly compelling
B Reese says I once spoke to a woman who
was against the death penalty she had
bumper stickers that mocked the death
penalty one time one said why do we kill
people who kill people to show that
killing people is wrong I said we don't
do that I said uh we kill people who
kill people so they don't kill more
people her response I hadn't thought
about that I said well think about it
after the death penalty is executed the
person will never have a will never be a
repeat offender never have a nice day
well you're right about that that is one
of the benefits of death penalty is that
the recidivism rate okay so we can talk
about the deterrence rate but certainly
the recidivism rate for the death
penalty is zero so that is a benefit of
it but
you know I wouldn't I wouldn't uh
I also wouldn't surrender to her
argument in that way like it's
yeah you can it is a valid method
to communicate the severity of a crime
through through the death penalty
so I mean look at it this way
kidnapping someone
right if you if I were to take someone
and lock them in a cage in my basement
I would be kidnapping them and I'd go to
jail for that
but I'm going to jail and they're
locking me in a cage so would this woman
say we shouldn't lock people in cages to
show them that locking people in cages
is wrong
now the answer to that is yeah that's
exactly what we should do what are you
talking about that's actually a great
way to show someone that what they've
done is wrong
okay if you don't know that locking
people to cages are wrong probably the
the best way to show you that it's wrong
is to put you in a cage how else what's
a better way
is a better way if you really want to
show them a lock and Publications wrong
is a better method to keep them out of a
cage and just uh sit them in a classroom
and you know and give them instruction
maybe have a have them talk to a
therapist
who tries to convince them by the force
of argument that they shouldn't lock
people in cages
now the best way to communicate it is
okay here's what that feels like here
you go
and so yes it is entirely valid
to make a societal statement
that uh that killing is wrong by killing
people who kill
that is an entirely valid method
and uh let's see what else finally
Kenny says let's we'll end on one person
who agrees with me anyway uh I was a
career criminal I was in prison guess
what Mr Walsh speaks truth and I have to
tell you Kenny that I that I I hear this
a lot for people who've actually been in
prison and who have lived a criminal
life and have uh come out on the other
end of it and have reformed themselves
they tend to be
bigger fans of Law and Order and
criminal justice and Punishment
then the people who have never
experienced this
and I think that probably tells you
something
yesterday I told you about how YouTube
removed an episode of our show because
my comments about men who want to have
uteruses and planted in their bodies
were deemed too offensive and hateful
well these restrictive speech policies
exist because the world is on a mission
to make you woke but our good friend
Dennis Prager is on a mission to make
you wise instead and thankfully Dennis
has created a brand new series with
daily wire plus called the Masters
program to do just that we've had a
long-standing relationship with Dennis
Prager for a good reason he's been
leading the charge against stupidity for
longer than I've been alive with content
like Prager use five minute videos and
and so many other things as well the
master's program takes 40 years worth of
wisdom and experience from one of the
most influential conservative thinkers
in America today distills it all down in
a way that is relevant and accessible to
everyone episodes explore topics like is
human nature basically good
um I think we could say for certain that
um I'm obviously good but I can't speak
for anyone else we'll see what Prager
says the series also covers the
consequence of consequences of
secularism which by the way are so dire
it needed two episodes to explore and
those two episodes of prageru Masters
program are available to stream right
now but only on daily wire plus so head
to dailywireplus.com to become a member
and watch prageru master's program and
more that's dailywireplus.com today now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
a little while ago when Elon Musk took
over Twitter and began making sweeping
layoffs he was condemned as a heartless
profiteer a man who took over a company
and gutted it out of spite or just for
fun but recent events would suggest that
musk was was only ripping the Band-Aid
off he was doing what needed to be done
but doing it in much in a much you know
quicker fashion a few months after those
layoffs the rest of big Tech is now
involved in its own Purge of its
Workforce the daily wire reported this
week quote Spotify revealed plans to cut
head counts by six percent due to
macroeconomic turmoil following similar
moves from other prominent technology
firms Spotify CEO Daniel eek or Eck
informed staff members in a mundane note
that the music and audio platform would
reduce head count to streamline
operations the announcement implies that
600 of the company's 9 800 employees
will lose their position Spotify is one
of these several technology companies to
announce layoffs in recent weeks as a
response to overzealous hiring in the
sector and broader economic woes
Microsoft revealed that the company
would dismiss some 10 000 employees
while Google would reduce its head count
by approximately 12 000 positions and
Amazon plans to dismiss 18 000 employees
more than 46 000 workers have been
discharged from prominent American
technology companies in the first month
of 2023 according to a report from
crunchbase even after firms in the
sector dismissed 107 000 positions last
year
so perhaps as it turns out the most
successful businessman in the world made
those layoffs because it was the right
business decision maybe he didn't become
the richest human in history by doing
things haphazardly or without good
reason
there's an interesting thought what's
even more interesting is that big Tech
employees themselves while still
complaining about layoffs have in the
past inadvertently revealed why the
layoffs were necessary
case in point Nicole Sai who's a partner
Services program manager at Google or I
should say a former partner Services
program manager at Google Psy like
several Infamous examples from the
Twitter ranks enjoyed posting these
insufferable Day in the Life videos to
tick tock where she documented her
exploits throughout the day which mostly
consisted of bragging about all the
perks that she enjoyed as a big Tech
minion I still remain you know
personally perplexed as to why or how
these Day in the Life videos become so
popular I can understand watching such a
video about somebody who lives an
interesting life
and does interesting things like maybe a
day in the life of a scuba diver who
explores shipwrecks or of a scientist on
a remote research station in Antarctica
or even one of those guys who repairs
power lines 150 feet up like I'd watch
that that a day in the life of that guy
I want to see
these are impressive jobs that would
make for fascinating content
a day in the life of a Silicon Valley
pencil Pusher doesn't exactly
measure up
yet even so Nicole Sai posted this here
it is
a day in my life working from the Google
LA office I always grab some candy from
the reception before heading in this
used to be an old aircraft hanger so the
decorations hanging from the ceiling
kind of looks like an aircraft flying in
before it was a Google office this
aircraft Hangar belonged to Howard
Hughes so there's tons of memorabilia
next I'm gonna pass by these art
installations they're a really good
photo op or you can sit in there and get
some work done I'm gonna head to the
coffee shop to grab some coffee and a
fruit cup since I missed breakfast and
then I'm heading over to this butterfly
themed room to take my first meeting and
I'm gonna head over to the confetti room
to take my next meeting it's so sparkly
and beautiful in here I love that a lot
of our rooms are themed then I'm gonna
grab my two favorite drinks which is
this green tea and coconut water next
I'm gonna go upstairs and grab some
lunch they always have pizza in a
variety of different vegetables and meat
the food is always really good and of
course everything you see in the office
is free on my way out of the cafe I ran
into a doogler which is a dog googler
and ran into some ghosts when they were
renovating the office there were a lot
of spooky stories from the crew so
there's a whole area in the office where
you can listen to them then I got more
work done and headed over to the massage
chairs to wrap up my day let me know
what you want to see next
[Music]
well it's important to get that massage
in after a grueling day of eating candy
drinking coconut water taking selfies
perusing art installations
petting the dog googler
Not In fairness she did take two
meetings Okay so there weren't too many
that and and that was her entire day she
had the two meetings and the rest of
that mostly just hobnobbing around
taking it easy
attending a meeting or two
the one thing missing from her day or uh
from uh from her day is is work
or anything that we might call work
she didn't like do anything or create
anything or make any important decisions
from the looks of it
it's not clear from that video why
Google needs her in the building and it
apparently wasn't clear to Google either
which led to this unintentionally
hilarious follow-up video here it is a
day in my life getting laid off at
Google so I woke up to this really
ominous text from my boss and I honestly
had no idea what it was going to be
about so I called her the minute I woke
up and saw this and she told me to check
the news and my email so I rushed
downstairs to find out that I had lost
access to basically everything I
couldn't log into my email or even check
my calendar I called my boss back and we
just sobbed over the phone because she
was also finding out about my layoff for
the first time today too I started
getting calls from a bunch of my
co-workers and started finding out who
else was let go on my team and some
neighboring teams as well but I think
the worst part is that it seems like no
one was consulted on this decision and
everyone was just finding out about the
layoffs at the same time it just felt
like a really bad game of Russian
Roulette and there was no consistency
around who was let go it was also not
Performance Based so it just felt really
random I opened up LinkedIn which
honestly was not not great for my mental
health there were so many people who
were in the same boat that were both
equally as shocked and blindsided but it
did help me feel a little less alone
honestly I spent so much of the day
crying that I just felt so tired from
being sad and wanted to do something
that would just make me feel better
luckily I have an annual pass so I
headed over to Disneyland because I
wanted to go eat my feelings so I
started off with a cinnamon Galaxy
churro and then went to the Teriyaki
Turkey Leg this is a special limited
edition item for the Lunar New Year
celebration at Disney California
Adventure I had some rice krispie a corn
dog did some drawing and even had
another churro I don't really know
what's next for me but I'll be vlogging
my journey and posting more content
about it so feel free to follow along
I you know I have a sick sense of humor
so I I really want someone with an even
sicker sense of humor to make a a video
parody video of like
what would happen if one of these people
was on like death row
and had to do a day in the life of their
execution I just think that'd be fun
here's a day in the life when I'm being
executed I Woke up had my last meal
a couple of things first of all she says
that the layoffs were a really bad game
of Russian Roulette which seems to
suggest that there's such a thing as a
good game of Russian Roulette the whole
point of Russian Roulette is that
someone dies at the end so it's going to
be a very bad day for someone at least
although maybe not for you so okay
second she she just got laid off lost
her source of income and her first
reaction was to run down to was it
Disneyland to blow her discretionary
funds on carnival snacks
doesn't seem like a great strategy
third listen I don't have anything
against this woman I'm um
predisposed to dislike her because she
works for big Tech but uh for all I know
she's a very nice and delightful person
for all I know but my ability to feel
sympathy for your tears is severely
limited when you take out your phone to
capture your tears on video
I have been sad in my life I've
experienced setbacks like we all I've
never once felt the urge in the midst of
that sadness to document it with my
phone that's actually the last thing I
would I would want is they're very sad
about something and then I have a phone
in my face it's the last thing I want
the instinct to pull out your phone
while you're crying is not one that I
can begin to understand and it
automatically makes your sadness at
least partially performative
because you're using it for Content
you're using it for clout
you're not taking your own Misfortune
seriously and so why should I take it
seriously
finally there's a lesson here that I
hope Nicole learns and all younger
people learn
um it's not
fun but it's it's the truth
in the Working World
everyone is expendable
everyone is replaceable
now you're not Expendable as a human
being I'm not saying that you as a human
are expendable you're not Expendable in
certain contexts like in the context of
your family you're not inexpendable
person but at your job you can be
replaced and eventually one way or
another you will be
whether you quit fired laid off retire I
mean one way or another eventually
you're replaced
and that's the case for all of us
but you can greatly mitigate your
replaceableness uh you can you can make
yourself much less Expendable you can
make it so that though you can still be
replaced there are not that many people
who can replace you
your own vulnerability in this regard
the reality that you will never be
entirely indispensable that shouldn't be
a cause for despair but rather it should
drive you and make you more ambitious
and Innovative and Propel you to work
harder
not a paranoid way but just in a like
staying humble and working hard kind of
way
and if it does if it does motivate you
that way then then even if and when you
are replaced
you're nearly certain to continue on the
path to success though by the way of a
detour
we will always be to one degree or
another Expendable at our jobs but you
can become virtually undeniable in
pursuit of your larger goals if you hone
your abilities if you never become
entirely complacent if you work harder
than everybody around you you will be
successful it is virtually guaranteed I
have never known in my life a
hard-working talented person who was not
by some measure successful
maybe not rich but rich is not rich is
is one potential manifestation of some
forms of success it is not in and of
itself success so maybe I'm not saying
that every hard-working childhood person
is is a millionaire
but they are all set successful at the
same time
so here's your problem Nicole and it's a
problem shared by many
you don't seem to be doing anything or
even attempting to do anything that
cannot be done by virtually anyone
that that is the most vulnerable
position you can put yourself in
when you are contributing in a way that
could just as well be emulated by nearly
anyone who walks in the door
in fact your contributions can be
absorbed by other people without
anything really being lost
you've made yourself highly highly
replaceable
and you've deprived yourself of any
Leverage
further down the professional ladder
there are some workers in the fast food
industry who find themselves in the same
position they clamor for higher wages
but they have almost no leverage because
their positions can be simply erased and
replaced by touch screens
now the best response then is to work
hard develop your skills become
Innovative put yourself in a position
either in the same industry or somewhere
else where you you you bring something
to the table
that very few people can match now this
isn't about defending corporations or
greedy billionaires I'm not telling you
how I wish things were
this is not my vision of how I want the
world to be
I'm telling you how it is
and all we can do is to start with
confront the fundamental reality for
what it is and figure out how to succeed
within its confines
whether you like the confines of reality
or not
there they are
have to figure out how to operate in
spite of them That's the Way Forward
though for now I must say you are still
canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
shows and move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]